さあ
でてっかーじゃんこれ絶対使う者
さあたまにはまさにくらいさとしても含めじゃあまずキスあ朝食をねじゃあ正木取締役
とシャッフルでスペダン
ボケボケでしょうか月回もちろんんだけどポケモンですね今やなぁ姫っていうの
ただいま全部で774書類
いるらしいでございます着々れたよねそう言うと姉774だよ
実はここでなんですけども僕は思ったわけですよ俺ポケモンの声わかるんですよねかっ
てんだ
いつもポケモンのゲームは駅次第以外は全部ちゃんと全クリしておりとやりこんでるん
だよね x y 以外のポケモンなら全部これが別れですある程度てるぞてーっ天帝
ペンテンってやつだな ua
2-6ぶー
へーん
受けちゃう
ん見てない俺っていうわけで今回はですね
私ポケモンがスティングの肇社長が今から真っ先にポケモンゴーの中と初代のポケモン
から適当にポケモンだ器具流してくれるのでそれがなんどポ擬音化を確実に当てて
いこうと思いますこれすごいようにわかった
ばわかんない絶対俺は俺はね分かるやったらまず兜の眼力だ乗っけるだけ絢爛つけるの
ケルンのチームでちょっとまだ作りやす増えいつから順番にレベル上げていきましょう
ねまずなぜかいた瞬間はれて湯川
高野台5部門ははいもうちょっと you ok
いつかはい一発であってくださぐっ
今はい
b か中畑にしてですよ青梅も簡単に行きましょうかいきますはい
んっ
これあれじゃねぇよくいるよねこれポッポーです
正解
空を飛ばないぞだ本でいきますはい
見えるネイルドゥヴァール
ずーっ
ぜひ壁で正解者にバーイ曲僕にとってメジャーあげちゃうッスこの日はバイ
dare
これは37 bp ではこれはないかみてください
[音楽]
えっそれぞれわかるかちょっ
yeah
[音楽]
ブーンろこんだ
世界一
るーぽん酢はくれよねえっこれ罰ポケ落ちた老舗やってやってくるよくいきますはい
そんなヤンキーの鳴き声のボケもいるその後 ikea 字幕お願いしまーす
うわぁ進化形と見てああいいいいたいんだ
その声が進化形の声だよもう1回
[音楽]
草タイプっぽいなぁいつも行かなきゃいけないん
ラフレシアじゃねえ税回マジでねー
一つで5 a
俺俺悦獄だけど俺まで行けそうだわこれ
はい
[拍手]
[音楽]
ぺぺちゃん食べ終え東京都できません
[拍手]
ううっうぅうううぅうえーそのパターンのポケモンはネロ本と急行の中では急行の声
叫んだよ喜ば風
聞くがいい
me
ふぅ
むずいなーこれ馬頭これ難しいでしょ覚えてください
ん
進化したような沈下してるのは分かるんだよねーむずむず本当にまず
こんなボケもいないよ言えるよくっさ
[音楽]
ああきたかも来たが起きたか多くても当ててんごろーんでしょ
前回車
ドレスを願う see the 次8問目ここらへんで
俺的にいやポケモンいきましたーーーいや何でも着ていける位までが池満載
写し方飼っんもういっちゃうわけ
顔ひきつってきた風月的でもう1回のか
うーんの進化なんですよねマジでわかんないよえっ
taboo 北再度んでしょ違う
me
あっ
何度高かったカイロスだ内側型ストライカーがこんなうぇうぇペットベター
ベトベトン正解
上田ケッ
嘘が本当星ないよ
真花よ花今日はなのでリズビ皆
アー株とだ世界
もう1回言っ
動画付じゃあまた度が違うなって次の超大ヒント
カリブラの面モハベ付も難しいぜひそこの
東京もの皆違うところですポケモントレーナーのみんな
ぜひ皆さんはポケモンのされて削ってみてくださいスパイダー